hey how's it going brother sister hi are
you ready are you ready to kill some
people
that's [ __ ] up what's wrong with you
someone told me there's a pretty pie
reference in this game how about bad
holy [ __ ] I really am the son of Satan
by the way there's a lot of satanic
references and [ __ ] like that so if
you're a friend dead and go home let's
go and be offended somewhere else
I'm kidding though tumblr go away go
away tumblr I want to murder people I
was burned down to the ground oh yeah we
couldn't save them all oh yeah that's
what I wanted to get the boy out and at
that time I was convinced it was his
father Charles oh yeah this situation is
the procedure was to take the boy to
psychiatric evaluation so I headed to
st. Benedict's house made me a very same
hospital he was born in big meat it was
only 50 hours that it once more he was
sitting quietly in a back seat staring
at me through the mirror some [ __ ]
arrived just before the nurses came to
get him he leaned forward and whispered
something Oh kinky the hair on the back
of my neck stood up as I was overwhelmed
with him that face whispers kept running
through my head that this was an
ordinary kid at all is that return to my
apartment I started with the pieces
together
now he realizes that it was all the boy
pointing at the boy yeah how can I not
see this before because you're a bad
dish groans right all along was I
actually helping oh damn that's nice
you're him Kim Kardashian no damn it can
to envision something telling you to do
the right thing oh yeah oh just part of
his plans my job is to make things
slightly more interesting hey that's
nice I'm also just a part of the plans
you have done what you were supposed to
do and you're going to do well but I'll
make it you started here underneath this
way you're just serving
and he is the one who actually devised
to be a coming rapture Wow which is
pretty much different twist on the whole
thing we are all just fulfilling his
wishes here
Wow if you put it that way listen to it
I've come up with for the boy now I was
conflicted but eventually I had to give
in all along I've been a servant to the
cause yeah oh he's giving Kim K a blow
job serving a Lucifer
it's his heresy son Lucifer had a plan
that was bringing everything seriously
suck his dick it was my job watch what
no no no no back oh I can't get over
that
what was that image but it's all
necessary sacrifice that will in the end
why did you have to blow him stir I mean
it's nothing wrong with that
he had lost his abilities to influence
anyone thoughts of abandonment
fell on his head his thirst for blood
was gone
it took six months until the boy was
walking again no blood was spilled
someone up there was happy brought two
new patients in they were both rambling
about a prophecy to make things more
interesting the other one was a woman of
the cloth immediately Lucius
realized that there was more than he had
to do so there was a fire inside him
again he was not just useful again
however the employees have managed to
put him down he was drugged dragged to
shock therapy
uh-huh nice the boy had gathered a
following throughout the hospital
some of the patients naturally look
after the boy I guess that makes an
interestingly shackled
ready to be shot but what they did not
know what they could not guess is the
answer to a question what happens the
devil's son Lucius to the Pepsi awesome
awesome
there is my main man my main [ __ ] it
take a big [ __ ]
sorry sorry
alright we have pills pills here and oh
that looks good
look at that I can see you the insides
very kinky and like it alright so we
have a bunch of stuff that we can do we
can grab this pudding is junk
is that it you oh yeah I got your key
buddy hey idiot stupid idiot
we're free hey what are you bobblehead
cool alright it looks like we'll have to
break free I want to break free he has a
great duck face I gotta get a hand eaten
locked oh ah ah ah not the cross
okay what's in here
Hey look so kawaai Oh are we gonna kill
him with a fan you bros gonna kill him
get him hahaha
sorry I'm so sorry we can do water
bottles just shove a water bottle down
his throat like a whack your boss okay
we messed so we can either poison the
coffee electrically electrically with
yes or break the ceiling fan I think the
fan would probably be the coolest make
some coffee
we just made some coffee so you can
throw objects in it oh god I got oh god
oh god oh god he almost saw me got a
break three oh my god Edgar's farts
combined with this game its intensity
man hey I'm not here I'm not here what
are you talking about what you talked
about did it work
oh no we just broke the TV
and I think we get many other chances
alright let's throw the doughnuts
[ __ ]
it's our only chance
yes I am pay bra bra sorry broad and
made a dude Jesus Christ he's like the
Joker look ma
that's so funny now what powered that
fan
I broke the TV to Emma I'm a proper
[ __ ]
no well progress wow we did it price
thanks so appreciate it alright who else
are we gonna turn XR we're gonna kill I
like the game so far it's pretty cool
you can just [ __ ] around as much as you
want I like a lot of [ __ ] Oh
children's boy okay oh oh they're all
open you get open I'm like Oprah Matt no
tell me what I do you're free I don't
like him can we kill him oh my god he
sounds so dumb
oh my god he's so annoying come back
here come back here sit down hey take a
seat take a seat take a seat right now
take a seat we've said that you need a
key for that [ __ ] well here's something
throw the cans break the hatch are these
camps yes
what does that do money I'll grab some
money what is he going from the inside
the room drag the cart and shoot you can
use tools to break them okay drag with
Edie what is that guy sound like Hitler
[ __ ] Hitler wannabe come here shut up
okay I got it I got a name on him now
what okay okay alright yeah keep dancing
buddy [ __ ] dancing Hitler stop it
Bagshot oh oh sweet titties look at that
damn buddy
oh man that's that's great oh god you're
a ragdoll aren't you damn football fat
man football my favorite football
I get mana from the toilet Wow
all right can we shoot someone else I
don't shoot more people okay come with
me
it's gonna be good I like how he's just
standing there not nothing suspicious
going down here buddy just gonna just
gonna shoot your head up yeah that's
that's this is gonna be so great oh my
God look at this look
Oh me that [ __ ] pregnant level up level
up got your key [ __ ] I got your key
[ __ ] ooh ooh he's still bleeding isn't
he that's very kinky I like you my hands
are full though you didn't see anything
should we kill him I don't like it
I like it what are you doing ping
a-plenty hey hey buddy I can see that
you don't even have a ding dong you
cheater
you're peeing through your outfit Oh
it's the fake Hitler again which would
be ooh what's happening here ooh kill
him hey hey hey why is this bass between
a woman's breasts and her head was
called the way
because you could easily fit another
baron kids in there
sorry a good one a good one salmon yeah
I got one how do you get when you put a
mintage rating may eat into a senators
mention an explosion what yeah what
throw an object inside alright hey we
need the flammable [ __ ] to go inside the
paint flap there we go got a little
present Christmas coming early
whoopsy oh ho ho MLG noscope
jabo cheer up we can unlock here hey
how's it go man Ludlow is this guy on to
me
okay cool level up in your face [ __ ]
we're gonna heat fuel all nearby flames
telekinetically control an object mind
control [ __ ] mind control man kill
them once they come back kill him twice
they are
I almost said black that would have been
foam oh nice nice
can we bring his head his head is coming
with us
awesome I'm gonna try something
different that we haven't done before
blue slippery slippery slow are we
missing someone back here oh it's him
slippery slow
slippery slippery slave slippery slave
oh he's slippery Slough he didn't fall
and I you're supposed to die
slippery snow haha ah damn it ah oh
there we go defibrillator all right
let's defibrillate ate him I was no one
there damn it
you're coming with me defibrillator what
a pipes going through the wall electric
current would run through them nicely
this seems too stupid that it would work
but let's do it hey we do it oh yeah
it's done so how do we make ah oh god oh
god attack attack attack defibrillator
oh the defibrillator is still coming
dammit defibrillators to us up we're
gonna have to shoot him do we have
another plier we do not have another
plier ira patch oh god i open this door
what hap
why is he dead but why he did though
detected detected it detected hey buddy
how's it going find your child fall over
that's kind of [ __ ] up I see a hand
out of nowhere there we go
don't follow me this time [ __ ] okay
where is he now alright he's going is he
gonna do it himself
I need to see this oh sweet burn your
brother Wow
stay toasty my friends know it I became
kendo first thing what are you doing
following me stop stop dancing stop
dancing stop dancing stop dancing stop
dancing stop dancing Kent stop dancing
on Kent stop dancing Oh what yes dance
did dance dance dance intent dance girl
dance that dance do that tolet dance Oh
stay away from me girl I were back here
there was one door that was locked
wasn't it find the nun strim finds an
answer assume it says it's in ya boom
bada bing bada boom
beautiful magical
amazing nailed it
level up what should we get
freight flames how why not yeah
paint paint bank the ball it's the name
given by pitiful to the red and white
ball founding game Bank you're back
I love you damn it [ __ ] awesome is it
loading hello level complete alright
price that was that's a lot of fun yeah
yeah let's continue brace the answers
were there so make questions without the
yeah how dare he when talking about this
small town called Ludlow what happened
there had the prophecy begun without him
prophecy begins when I face out very on
it newspapers describing better the
events of Ludlow the boy also had more
followers on this floor may soon be
called a zebras my fans yeah help me
kill people please sadly crate that loud
well Wow sorry yeah alright let's do
these press you ready to kill some
people
Wow can never be not excited about
murder especially if your little boy
hey backs hey nothing suspicious going
on here against yes going everywhere has
and emits green I'm just kidding just
gonna go in here now big dick it's like
it's a coffee I hear excuse me lady
excuse me milady we're gonna we're gonna
place in your coffee aren't we yeah but
how oh sorry Ken I'll need that for
later let's try in here [ __ ] it
Gloria Williams you're deaf we'll be
gone oh hey ginger
how rare excuse me thank you try to stay
out of people's way kid you say that to
the door Oh God okay okay thanks Judy I
really appreciate your concern we're
gonna did I broke the soda can this soda
can is broken and the liquid is slippery
no that's mine Oh [ __ ] fell well we
have a can of noodles and [ __ ] so let's
use that where's the [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] there you go
I want to break this bra Oh perfect
timing perfect timing perfect timing yes
but how how does that work I mean of
course how that's what you get for
taking my soda little [ __ ] right now we
need to hide the evidence from the
ginger nice shoe you have there oh my
god in her [ __ ] forehead her back
head fell off
oh my god she doesn't have a back had
not a backhand in ten oh my god that is
that is Nia stay Hey oh my god we're
gonna have to kill the ginger guy next
well I can use you I guess pretty pretty
blonde let's see here
oh there's a junior man a pretty big
baby baby get it up hahahaha you're
still making out with that door right I
get it
[ __ ] high stay toasty brewski stay
toasty what do we got here dr. Carson
Hill a lazy doctor on nightshift
responsible of patients on this wing
well he's doing a great job wicked
you're saving people's life
let's poison his doughnuts cuz Yolo how
do we make him eat it though
he's like what doughnuts
there's obviously pills in there oh no
oh no idiot good job being responsible
for people [ __ ] idiot
hey dance break dance nice yeah
that's what I'm talking man you will
know thy name there can only be hahaha I
don't know your birth could read that
maybe it's too tiny
I wonder if we can misplace these I know
I saw another one that'd be cool cool
way to kill someone
thank you imagine if you're so hungry
eat this yes yes Wow
that's right you can now be ginger in
hell
okay not in Florida Gloria
and Gloria's gonna freak out Gloria's
gonna print them
oh she busted what what what is wha wha
wha ah ah gah yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] are
you insane
oh my god what was that what was that
she pulled me through the [ __ ] wall
oh my god I get so [ __ ] into these
games just murdering people makes me so
excited
it's like Christmas for me crap headshot
where's your jaw don't follow me Charlie
[ __ ] ooh ooh nice I like when they
splatter a little bit let's put him here
so Gloria doesn't freak the [ __ ] out
again stay stay stay stay stay
can we shoot someone else I'm gonna yes
I want to kill everyone
Charlie are you coming coming Puetz
Cammy pigs all right mixes don't worry
don't worry don't worry guys don't worry
about it I don't worry about just
graduated from college
yeah yeah yeah that's well that's so
great that's so cute yeah
is that a double is that a double kill
that lady's umbrellas is it it's not a
double cam Charlie Sarah
don't worry about Sarah Sarah Sarah
Sarah I want you to become out your
strong independent woman that needs to
run in there and die don't worry about
your panic hi oh and you got Zebedee
Zubat it's a pit is looped as I like to
call it and sapidus ooh my favorite
[ __ ] amazing [ __ ] Charlie are you
still following me
alright [ __ ] god dammit hey what are
you doing something in here yes Oh
goddamnit sister I gotta throw waste of
coke just on you BAM oh god it looked
like a what kind of coke is this Jesus
we're gonna do with this pillow pillow
my Marie there you go nice and
comfortable I like I like to be yes -
sir general oh she died from pillow
oh god no not to pillow anything but the
pillow the prophecy of the seven
trumpets the writings explain how these
events would unfold and bring rapture
hey hey you're dead horn
she's my trophy now at all did we kill
everyone serious are you still alive oh
we need to kill her she's the one we
need to kill we were gonna poison her
coffee right do we have any point we
still don't have any [ __ ] poison my
god hey just making coffee just make
curtain for you I love you how do we
kill a [ __ ] like her root pills yes
here hello so we are almost there we
just need to get past [ __ ] Gloria
it's the son of a [ __ ] there we are
alright Bryce let's do this alright so
now the waters [ __ ] up we can take
glory at this woman oh my god what [ __ ]
I'm supposed to be on you are gonna die
now what oh there we go
wonderful
just as I like them extra crispy Wow got
your key [ __ ] and I'm levitating that's
[ __ ] awesome alright let's go to our
follower which says in the map is here
was this oh my god he's he's an angel oh
my god we have like an opposite Lucifer
maybe
oh my god I'm gonna be so pissed well
that's that's cute that's cute you're
cute
Kawai how I did that activate to cut
scenes at once what is this okay cool
they worked out what goes on in here is
that what I think it's oh yeah yeah
lunch box I love you baby
Oh broke yeah I kill everyone we heal
everyone is dead this is awesome
riding my bike like a pimp okay so last
one is in here
hey buddy how you doing
hey do it that's a [ __ ] get riding
with my top down net Mysterio just get
my hood on I'm just I'm just doing my
thing I'm just doing my thing that's
right baby
that's how I roll that time I get all
the late I need this well well well II
really well well well sighs chapter 2
level 225 party counts pretty good
satanic Chia Satan Satan atcha very well
very well well well well well well I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode I'm
having a lot of fun playing this with
you and if you want more please go ahead
and leave that like button alike on that
bike thanks for watching as always I'll
see in the neckline stay awesome gross